So far we've explored the idea that we
should prefer heavier augmenting paths.
It turns out that the idea
of using shorter paths
also gives rise to
an efficient algorithm.
This is the Edmonds-Karp algorithm,
also discovered independently
by Dinitz in the Soviet Union.
Again, this is exactly
the Ford-Fulkerson algorithm,
only we are sure to choose
a minimum length path.
The cost of an iteration is order E,
as always, as we just use breadth-first
search to find the shortest s-t path.
If we can bound the number
of iterations, most likely
we'll have a better bound than we did
for the naive version of Ford-Fulkerson.
Indeed, we will be able to bound
the number of iterations here
as order E times V.
And this, then, will enable us to argue
that Edmonds-Karp returns a maximum flow
in time E squared V.